Olha só, você sabia que aquele coloral
da sua cozinha pode ser um aliado
poderoso contra a gordura do fígado?
Pois é, pesquisadores da Unicamp
descobriram que o extrato de urucum,
sim, aquela sementinha vermelha que a
gente usa para temperar, tem
propriedades incríveis. Veja bem, o óleo
extraído dessas sementes é rico em
tocotrienol e geranil geraniol. São dois
compostos que ajudam a reduzir a gordura
acumulada no fígado e ainda controla o
colesterol. O melhor de tudo, diferente
de muitos medicamentos, não tem
contraindicações. Já está até disponível
como suplemento em farmácia de
manipulação, mas óbvio, precisa de
prescrição médica. Que tal incluir mais
coloral natural na sua comida? E se você
tem gordura no fígado, vale conversar
com o seu médico sobre esse suplemento.
Me conta depois o que que você achou. M.